um thank you and welcome to the
subcommittee meeting on House Bill
368 I'm calling this order to this
meeting to
order sorry 378 I apologize I'm not
trying to jump the gun for next Friday I
promise this is the 378 subcommittee um
this is the bill that is titled an act
requiring a healthc care provider to
inform an offer to take and preserve
blood and urine samples from a patient
who may have been drugged or sexually
assaulted um when we met earlier in the
spring um we had a lot of discussion
around this and there was a lot of
concern about the idea of who would be
included um on a closer review of the
action ual language as opposed to the
intent that I know which is so that if
somebody has been attempted to be
sexually assaulted they know their
rights um I I've seen that when you look
at the actual bill on line six says if a
patient asserts that they may have been
drugged it does not say drugged for the
purpose of sexual assault sexually
assaulted or then going from line six to
seven subject to an attempted assault
that was always intended to say or
subject to a attempted sexual assault or
drug for the purposes of furthering a
sexual assault so there was a huge
amount of confusion around that um by
some people who had read this bill and
come came in not knowing the intent
behind and they thought that this was
going to massively increase the scope
and then put rape kits to use in areas
where there was not sexual assault
involved um I truly believe that's
probably why this whole bill was
derailed because all that this bill is
doing is putting again into statute
rights that already exist
um but are unfortunately not well
known there's a copy of the statutes I
believe everybody has one but if you
look
M18 it's um one of the stacks of those I
can give you mine where I put all of the
sexual lists out the third page of the
yes so if
you on the third page um just above from
just a second line from the bottom it
says the right to be informed of the
rights under this section um some of
those rights if you look up a little
further number three uh B3 it says that
you have the right to be informed in
writing of policies governing the
collection and preservation of a sexual
assault evidence collection kit so you
have the right to be informed
the question is how are you informed and
I think that that's really the Crux of
this issue um if you look at page four
which is section 21-
m19 yes oh if you do the microphone
since we are recorded and
broadcasting I'm still not on
there of the yeah the the third and
fourth page is the statute so um first
we were looking at the third page page
of the statute right towards the bottom
the second to last line D what's the
number um the the third page is um M
colon
18 21-m
18 and so on line D it says the right to
be informed of the rights under this
section and then if you look up higher
under B3 it says to be in the right to
be informed in writing of policies
governing the collection and
preservation of a sexual assault
evidence collection kit at the point of
care that notification depends a lot on
the training and knowledge of those
providers um so I'll move you to page
four which is 21- m19 the notification
of sexual assault survivors
rights this is where the Attorney
General um in in Roman 1 the Attorney
General shall provide written notice
regarding sexual assault survivors
rights in RSA 21- M18 to medical centers
hospitals forensic examiners sexual
assault services providers state and
local law enforcement agencies any any
other state agency or Department
reasonably likely to serve sexual
assault survivors and shall make the
information set forth in RSA 21-m 18
publicly available on the Attorney
General's
website now I will take you to the
excerpt that I've provided you and that
you were provided a different excerpt at
the hearing this is um I had given it to
you right underneath the one that has
some supposed language um with notes
that give you a breadcrumb trail this is
six it's right underneath the one right
there
yes this is 16 pages of 124 page
document that I was only able to find on
the Attorney General's website by
Googling for the name of it it is
available but it's hard to find for
providers and especially for survivors
of sexual assault
um going through there's a lot of rights
that are established and it's an amazing
the amount of work that went into this
we heard from s counselors at the
initial hearing about how much work they
have done and how carefully they have
worked this
process the4 pages is the result of that
as well as another 100 plus page um
document that pretty much has checklists
and uh basically flight takeoff lists
for every single provider um who will
interact with people there's nothing
like that for the
Survivor that's something that I think
is actually quite critical
because um I I'd say because sexual
assault is so common it's so isolating
and you don't know where to turn and
your world's just been turned upside
down yes so what you just said is this
is the the document for the hospitals
the doctor offices and whatever and what
you just said is that there's not a
similar kind of document about what to
do if you're the victim or the Survivor
very close this is 16 pages of the 124
page document but yes yes I just wanted
to be clear of what you said okay thank
you their rights are outlined here your
right your rights as a Survivor are
outlined here I spent six hours reading
through it and there were Parts I only
skimmed um so it is it's
dense um
when you're informed of your rights it's
important to actually be able to
understand it and there was also some
misunderstanding among people who are
highly involved in sexual assault and
sexual assault Survivor Care at the
hearing there was confusion about
whether sexual assault requires
penetration um I have the criminal code
of all of the sexual assault fil all the
sexual assault we have aggravated fonia
sexual assault which is what people
typically think of as rape um we have
felonia sexual assault which is what's
generally considered statutory rape and
then we have misdemeanor sexual assault
that is basically it would be raped
except it was not penetrate so you may
have grabbed somebody you may have been
you may have been trying to rape them
but you were only able to get a hold of
them or try to get a hold of them um so
that is against the law and that
actually is in all the information
provided by the Coalition on the
Attorney General's
website but it takes little work to find
it so that's representative
pushman um just a thought that might be
helpful too even on the fonia sexual
assault it doesn't require penetration
if it's um if there's a uh Power um
relationship and yeah so there's a
couple of if it's a m if there's a if
it's a minor there's a couple of other
um variables that even without
penetration it could still be the
highest um degree of a charge thank
thank you thank you yes this is very
very complex I appreciate that
clarification um yes it's that the
aggravated fonia sexual assault is uh
RSA 632-a colon 2 um and perhaps the
most important part going back down this
breadcrumb Trail on the laws is um in
the definitions for the sexual assault
and related offenses it's the criminal
code I'm not sure if anybody if we have
this copy of the criminal code so I will
pass this out pass those two over I'll
pass these two
over I know I'm killing trees but I want
to make sure that we're protecting
survivors so this has those statutes for
the aggravated felonius felonius and
misdemeanor and at the top is the
definitions and I bolded um Roman 4
which is the definition of sexual
contact that means the intentional
touching whether directly through
clothing or otherwise of the victim or
actors sexual or intimate Parts in
including emissions tongue breast and
buttocks sexual contact only includes
that of forment cond conduct which could
be reasonably construed as being for the
purpose of sexual arousal or
gratification or the humiliation of the
person being touched so that is what the
standard is and the misdemeanor um
there's all the different permutations
but just going down to the
basics um we're just looking to
those um
so trying to deal with this
misunderstanding trying to deal with
this lack of information um it I I've
been looking at this and I think that
probably the best way to move forward is
to give a specific list of rights that
need to be enumerated to survivors
that's including but not limited to um
and as we move forward with this um I'd
actually like to see what the prime
sponsor alen Reed um has to provide
input for us
here so is
ises two page thing is this this is your
proposal um both representative Leon and
I worked on that proposal together and I
can explain it a little bit more I I did
want to also as uh I guess I should say
Madam chair of the subcommittee um had
um been going through the definitions of
sexual assault which is 632 a23 and 4 um
under 632
A2
uh uh item item lettered
is the specific statute that makes
drugging for the purposes of sexual
assault also fall under the definition
of sexual assault um so I just wanted to
outline that so uh as representative Lon
or I should say Madam chair uh had has
spelled out and I'm sorry I'm having
difficulty talking you know you probably
know this personally impacts
me we have in law the absolute
unequivocal unequivocal right for
victims to have a kid to be informed of
their rights it's so much work has been
into this we put this into law and then
we went one step further and said the
AG's office has to then send out
instructions in the form of two over 100
page documents in addition to the the
survivors rights which is um that third
page 18 and all of that has to be sent
to every medical provider and law law
enforcement officer we went through all
of this we even expanded those rights to
make sure it covered deceased people
right people who had already passed away
even though they had had a sexual
assault but we did not close the gap
because while all the providers and Law
Enforcement Officers but I'm speaking
primarily of providers have to be
informed by the AG's office there is
nothing making those providers inform
the patients the victims of their
rights and since there's nothing holding
holding their feet to the fire to to
inform their patients that means that
there's no reason for them to actually
read that AG's guidance that is by law
has to be sent to them so I'm just
looking to close the loop I'm we said we
have these rights even to the point that
the state has said we will pay for your
medical exam your visit to the ER if you
don't have insurance the state will pay
and it's even if you are deceased and we
have these rights in law and the AG's
office by law has to send out the
notification but we didn't close the
loop because I think at the time that we
wrote this we added this to law we just
presumed of course of course a doctor
will inform their patients of their
rights of course a law enforcement
officer will inform a victim of their
rights but that has and not just in my
case but also in uh Linda rule who's the
victim Advocate at the AG's office told
me twice over two separate phone calls
that this is a pandemic of doctors who
do not understand what con Institute
sexual assault they're not lawyers they
don't understand because we colloquially
call it a rape kit they think there has
to be
penetration and because it's because
they think that they don't understand
that they can submit any separate
element of that state collection kit
individually that you don't have to have
a swab a vaginal swab in order to have
urine tests for
drugging etc etc so I'm just looking to
close the loop we said that they have
the rights we told the AG's office that
they have to inform all the providers of
those rights and now we need to make
sure the providers who are the ones in
contact with the victims inform the
victims of their rights and that's all
and I'm I'm sorry for maybe waxing
philosophic right there but um so I I
have told representative Leon that she
is my hero for this issue and she truly
this um so the if if if I can ask you to
look at the language uh that is titled
Amendment it's just plain language I did
have an amendment drafted but we uh
representative Lan and I worked further
on it so it's this is not an official
Amendment yet this is all going into uh
18 which is the survivors basically the
sexual assault survivors Bill of Rights
M18 and there are three changes that we
are proposing to make and I I have a a a
um an additional comment on the
back yes
Weber so is this in the same format that
OS usually gives us so that the the
matter that's in plain text is already a
matter of Law and what you are proposing
is just the the the only changes to
existing law are the bolded and
italicized B that is correct
representative Le that this is is
everything you see here is existing law
with the exception of the bolded
italicized pieces that relieves my mind
considerably yes indeed indeed and I'm
sorry I didn't have it as an official
Amendment
yet
yeah the the three changes that I have
here um under paragraph one again
existing language it says in addition to
the rights of a crime victim and it
cites the crime victim's Bill of Rights
a sexual assault surv driver shall have
the following rights the right to not be
prevented from or charged for receiving
a medical examination that is already in
law that is already in law what we are
adding here is including any individual
element or elements of a state sexual
assault evidence collection
kit and if I may pipe in right here that
is within the rights it's just buried
within the 124 page document precisely
it is in policy and a document that I I
read yeah and I would say that probably
one of the things that needs to happen
is this needs to be a one-pager because
there's no doctor I
mean probably probably no Doctor Who who
has time to read 124 pages on one thing
where what we're going to effectively do
is um you know or what happens in R I'm
not an ER provider but what happens in R
is um that the ER provider uh will call
the San nurse who will do all of this
right and so the what
I what what I'd want to do is just I
don't know we if we want to add this to
the bill but I I think the expectation
that all the ER doctors in New Hampshire
are going to read 124 page document on
this when they're trying to remember how
to treat a dissecting aneurysm and also
just what their process in the ER should
be for anyone who's um coming in with a
question of sexual assault um so we just
somehow need to close that Loop so that
there's some simple thing where the
physician isn't you know stuck in this
thing having to be a lawyer you've just
add me yes that's exactly what we're
trying to do here is to make it a this
is what a doctor needs to do this is
what a doctor is responsible for knowing
um and so like I said representative
Leon and I have have worked and I would
say especially her at this stage um to
simplify that I do want to go back to
your comment earlier about the San
program so one of these and this is why
I believe um we experienced push back on
this bill because I think it was the
perception was is that this was somehow
stepping on the toes of the same program
um which it it isn't because indeed in
fact it actually enhances that program
because as in was in my case if a doctor
doesn't understand what sexual assault
is the doctor won't call a San nurse and
no say nurse was called for
me even though I insisted on the state
kit so
anyway so the first piece is clarifying
that and and it's actually in a later um
section of law that specifically says
the uh State uh evidence collection kit
but we're just at taking that from that
section of Law and duplicating it here
as well saying and and adding that it
includes any individual element
or
elements um and then as representative
Leon already said there's these rights
uh be aware of B3 which is to be
informed in writing of the policies
because I'll I'll Circle back around to
that in a second the second change is
paragraph two where we realized that
sexual assault Survivor was not actually
defined anywhere in any of these
rsas um and there was confusion from
even the uh supposed experts about what
con instituted sexual assault and so we
very clearly and specifically it's a bit
redundant for the doctors specifically
because the rsas that cover sexual
assault are RSA 632 a23 and 4 but here
we spell it out in language here as well
so sexual assault Survivor means any
individual who asserts that they have
been sexually assaulted or subjected to
an attempted sexual assault including
non-penetrative assault sexual assault
the administering of a drug or other
intoxicating substance is part of is
part of an attempted sexual assault and
any offense so actually those rsas
already cover the non-penetrative and
cover the uh administering of an
intoxicating substance but we spelled
that out there because we want the
doctors to be able to understand
immediately um and this would be this is
the sexual this 18 the whole section is
um the sexual assault survivors buil
like rights so I think what we for or
see is this being a written one pager
that doctors then give to their patients
and then the the final uh and by the way
that same so there was a mention of the
definition of sexual assault Survivor
but only to say that it included a
deceased victim so someone who' passed
away since their since their assault so
we obviously kept that in the definition
but we added the clarifying what that
meant um referencing those rsas that
Define sexual assault
and then the last change here is um a
new paragraph which is the mandate to
inform the victims so if I can take you
back to uh that your little packet of
existing law the last page which should
be
m19 yes
ma'am you're going very quickly and I
appreciate that problem I I need just a
minute to read section three because
there's a lot of stuff that's just oh no
I was I was about to I was going to read
it but I wanted to as context point out
19 because it references
19 if I may Madam chair I I learn with
my eyes not with my ears so if if you
wouldn't mind just giving me a moment to
read it then I would love toen to your
explanation I just I just for my own
benefit I will I will thank you we'll
take that pause to accommodate
everybody's processes it's it's a lot to
digest and it's a lot of pieces of paper
if
okay thank you okay so um I'll I
apologize for going quickly um the new
paragraph simply says a healthc care
provider law enforcement officer or
other employee of an entity listed in
RSA 21 m19 which was what I was asking
people to turn to um who in the course
of their professional responsibilities
has contact with a sexual assault
Survivor shall provide the individual
with written notice of their rights
under this section which is the sexual
assault survivors Bill of Rights and RSA
m19 and I'm going to underline this
piece and of the policies governing the
collection and preservation because that
goes back to B3 and that's what the
notes on the back are um but I wanted to
point out that 19 the the RSA that this
references is the law that says the AG's
office has to send out that big 124 page
document of which you have a few pages
it's that law that says the AG's office
has to send that out and it ex it
enumerates who it has to send out that
information to to so it says the
Attorney General shall provide written
notice regarding sexual assault
survivors rights which is 18 to medical
centers hospitals sexual assault service
providers state and local law
enforcement agencies and any other state
agency or Department that reasonably
likely to serve as sexual assault
survivors so that's where the AG's
office is telling all the the
professionals what those rights are but
there's nothing saying that those
professionals now have to tell the
victims what their rights are so we are
referencing this list of entities and
saying that list of entities now has to
transmit those rights to the victim
where I underlined the last piece so now
we're saying that this this list of
entities has to tell the victims of
their rights under the sexual assault
survivors Bill of Rights in addition
there's extra rights under 19 under
paragraph Roman numeral
2 um and then and of the policies
governing which goes back to B3 and if
now you want to turn over the page
actually if I could pause you for just
one moment um as we're working through
this especially with the input of
Representative Palmer um I think we
perhaps should actually look at
requiring a form to be produced and
having that go through the rules process
that includes these rights we're going
to discuss and that that form needs to
be provided by the providers because um
my my thought there is that then the
provider sees it as they're providing it
and so does the patient representative
Weber I'm just wondering whether that
needs to happen in that format I mean my
understanding and and representative
Palmer can correct me if this doesn't
happen is that any medical care
providers Professional
Organization will be updating them as a
matter of course as they do anytime the
statutes
change and uh is that not not a more
effective way of
communicating ra changes in the law
rather than requiring a form which is
then another lot of
verbiage for somebody who's really busy
to not
read um I I I know when I and I'm just
going back to my time as an attorney
when there were changes in the law we
got memos from the bar association that
said you should be aware of
ABCDE and I I don't know whether that's
an appropriate way of dealing with it or
whether you two feel that an actual form
needs to be created either in statute or
in rules I'm trying to keep this as as
simple as possible because the more
complexity we add the less the the more
things there are to run a ground on
indeed and I you know the the basic
intent is clear so so so representative
Palmer then kushman then n so yeah I
think that this
can't I think the testimony that we
heard from the ER people aside from any
of the other concerns were just that
that if this becomes too cumbersome
they're they're already there people in
the waiting room who are sick they're
this this has to be something that that
they can have work quickly what
representative Weber said is true is
that we get you know and it's mostly
through the hospital H for for me I work
in the hospital so then when there rule
changes and things we get notified um we
have regular meetings we get notified
what I'm wondering is this is a little
bit in the same kind of thing as if
you're if someone comes in and you
expect child abuse or elder abuse we're
mandated to report it but it's not a
huge amount of paperwork for us we
report then the legal people the people
who do that take over and that's what I
think needs to happen here is we we need
need to be able to get this absolutely
make sure that that that the the
victim has is informed of all of this
but have it work in a way that is not
going to be so cumbersome that for um
because that could work against you I
mean I'm you know like in a really
borderline case if I'm the ER provider
and I'm really busy I could sort of go I
don't think this is really what's going
on as opposed to oh this is category
this category this is where we need to
go this is who I need to
inform now I just can focus on the
medical aspects of this and other people
will take over it with the legal and all
of that kind of stuff so and I don't I'm
not representative
kushman thank you madam chair um yeah I
I'm not sure I feel like just printing
these two statutes 18 and 19 and having
them available I mean we have the
patient Bill of Rights uh statute
available at all the healthcare
facilities it's posted and then it's
available for um review um so I'm not
sure that a form would be necessary it
might be just if we want to really um
like boil it down to um but this is
pretty straightforward also but I'm also
used to reading legal ease so
representative nut appam and then
representative Weber I think I'm good to
got
covered I think that representative of
Palmer's point is met by the definition
in two which says any individual who
asserts they have been sexually
assaulted or subjected to attempted
sexual assault including
non-penetrative the administering of a
jugg or other intoxicating substance as
part of an attempted sexual
assault um or the offenses and maybe you
you write something out about that but
it the language as I read it
leaves the patient in control of what
they say and what they assert and as
soon as they have asserted something
just as in the case of child abuse then
you have
triggered everything else and that makes
it I
think accept I I don't know if it's
acceptable or not really sort of unhappy
that a lot of people aren't here to
listen to this discussion who work in
the field but it it seems to me that
that is not an unreasonable ask of an
emergency room physician who's trying to
deal with stuff very
quickly if the patient says this
happened or I think this happened then
that triggers a report and that takes
and then the the doc goes on treating or
or dealing with the
protocol so I I think that in many ways
gets rid of some of the the issues I
think um clarifying offenses under 632
A2 A3 and A4 might be helpful for people
but so that people see that in words
rather than as as a statutory reference
but I think for me that kind of gets us
out of the
form
business and into the quick treatment
business and into a quick referral to
the people who are then trained to deal
with the issues and so that that's just
my comment on um that's very helpful
this has been a helpful conversation my
thought was you could hand somebody a
pamphlet but you don't want to sit in
the waiting room with a pamphlet better
to have something that looks like legal
e I'm representative Reed
um so so much of what I had to say has
been touched on but I'll just do my best
to connect it and um the patients
existing Patient Bill of Rights was
brought up and that's exactly what I was
thinking it's a one-pager um it's
available at every healthc Care Facility
um representative Weber is exactly right
that this is the trigger if someone says
that they were assaulted or someone
attempted to assault them sexually
assault them then that's what triggers
the um doctor having to inform them and
between this sexual assault Survivor
Bill of Rights and the additional rights
in 19 which I'm not sure why they are
not included in the sexual assault
survivors Bill of Rights um but there
are additional rights and some of them
are are
duplicative um that that literally will
would fit easily on a single piece of
paper so I think representative Leon and
I both had the the vision that there
would be a a pamphlet that if you said
that you were sexually assaulted the
doctor then or a nurse or whoever gives
it to you um and if you want to cover
yourself perhaps gets a signature for
the saying that they had received it but
that's that's it I just want to clarify
because you mentioned mandatory
reporting it's actually you you can't do
that under you can't report it uh
against their wishes that would be
illegal so that's not mandatory
reporting it's mandatory informing of
their rights but I I understand what
you're saying there's there's certain
things that doctors are required to do
Beyond simple Medical Care not that
Medical Care is simple so so yes so
you're I see your point and what I was
thinking of is as as somebody working
you know my I I am required to do
something here in the case of the child
abuse I'm required to report it in this
case what I would be required to do is
ask the patient and if they say yes I
want to purs pursue this then then I
need to trigger that so that's separate
that's a separ whether or not they
prosecute no no I'm sorry what I meant
is whether the
patient I
I'm if if what I'm required to do as a
physician in the ER is is I see this
patient who looks like they may have
been assaulted is I inform them that
they have rights to this and if they
want to pursue it then what I would what
I would like to see is that then what I
do as a physician is I trigger the whole
process the same process and then I'm
documenting that I've done this and then
if we have information to give the
patient about exactly what their rights
are that we do that too but I don't have
to do that as a physician I just have to
trigger all of that happening because I
don't have time to be the one who prints
off the document and do all of that
stuff um so actually if I may go to the
guidance that's in there um the guidance
actually says that when it's reported um
it needs to be treated as a medical
emergency and as soon as possible the
patient should be escorted to a private
location in the hospital hospital and
the hospital shall immediately call an
advocate from the local crisis center to
meet with the patient and the patient is
allowed to meet privately with them so
that nothing ends up in the medical
record this was my notes coming from
section this is let's see that's the
conversation one two three that's the
third one that would be on page nine I
believe in here I did not quite cross
reference correctly I can I I'll give
you it's from the
yes in
and what is advisory opinion yes thank
you um yes all of the I have a
breadcrumb trail for everything that is
within um within the guidance which was
created through statute so um I don't
believe it went through I didn't see it
in the roeming process um but it I
believe his guidance has quite a bit of
heft even if it's not
statute to to respond to representative
Palmer um so the way you said it sounded
a little backwards to me so the way I
see it and I'm happy to engage in this
conversation is if someone says that
they were sexually assaulted the first
thing you do as a physician or a nurse
or whoever and I presume you would have
these printed out already pamphlets
ready to go for anyone saying that they
were sexually assaulted and you tell
them here are your rights and then they
realize they have the option to safe
have a state kit and then they can
pursue that and yes it also triggers
calling
uh an advocate or Sayan nurse and all of
those other things but that you know as
far as the first line of defense you
have to let them know what their rights
are um so and then um I'll let you
answer that in reference we have my copy
of the attorney generals it's page nine
which is actually the second top of the
second page has the emergency response
I'm I'm not questioning the law or any
of that and and as I'm remembering back
in the day when I used to work in the ER
is that there was one of the our really
good year nurses was a San nurse and
basically we just you know I would just
go Jean what do I do okay so that was
really helpful but I've a little bit
lost its right because I don't work in
the e but the reason I said it the way I
said it was the wording that you have in
in in this which is that from a patient
who may have been drugged or sexually
assaulted so what I wasn't saying that I
wasn't discounting that the idea that
that the patient might say I you know I
think I was drugged for the purpose
of but that I might suspect it even
though the patient's not saying anything
and then bring it up now if that's not
your intent that that's fine but this
this sort of leaves it in the in the
realm of I was thinking of it the way I
think of like elder abuse which is what
I see which is that the patient may not
be complaining of that but you suspect
it and so at that point do you bring it
up and so um I completely get your idea
of the patient says you know this guy
tried to do whatever um that I that that
should trigger it but should it I guess
my question to you is should it be
triggered if I just suspect that but the
patient's not saying anything because
they're afraid to or whatever um so that
actually is within the guidance and
guidelines as well um which is which is
which is critical because there actually
is a discussion about the elder abuse
issue because if you um have a sex
attempted sexual assault on a vulnerable
person whether they're elderly or
otherwise vulnerable um that does
escalate it as well um and I think that
your procedure of notifying Jean the
same nurse actually was exactly what the
process is so what I would say is what
this is saying is where the notification
rights is absolutely required there's
nothing preventing a physician who
thinks that someone may have been
sexually assaulted to be like by the way
in case you were sexually assaulted here
are your rights you don't have to report
it to law enforcement you don't have to
make that decision you can get collect
evidence right now so you can out of you
know as a physician out of your own
wisdom decide to go beyond just the
minimum requirement of this person said
that they were a victim I have to inform
them and go maybe they are a victim I
better inform them anyway there's
nothing stopping you and any good doctor
I think would do that um but uh this is
just the legal trigger for when you
absolutely had have to um could I have
you run through that list of um of
rights that you that we think probably
should be enumerated so the patients can
know I'm very happy to so representative
Lon did the hard work of going through
the
124 pages and kind of boiling down the
most essential of those rights that are
in the AG's guidance so these are
additional rights in the AG's guidance
they're not in statute that is the back
of page the back of the suggested
wording and so what she was suggesting
and I understand it's a lot of extra
language but I would wholeheartedly
support adding um the codification of
these rights that are currently just in
the AG guidance um so this would be
added under on the on the suggested
language would be added under three to
be informed of in writing of policies
governing the collection and
preservation of a sexual assault
evidence collection
kids including but not limited to the
following a the sexual assault does not
only include
penetration B most sexual assault cases
of patients over the age of 18 are not
required to be reported to police and in
these circumstances evidence can be
collected anonymously if their survivors
unsure about reporting to the assault to
police C that sexual assault exams are
conducted in hospitals and by sexual
assault nurse examiners if available at
that hospital and a sexual assault is to
be treated by the hospital as a medical
emergency D that as soon as possible the
patient should be escorted to a private
location in the hospital and the
hospital shall immediately call for an
call an advocate from the local crisis
center to meet with the patient and the
patient can meet privately with the
advocate for confidential conversation e
that blood Andor urine is only collected
if it is suspected that drugs were used
to enable a sexual assault within the
prior 120
hours that the survivor's consent is
required for each portion of the exam
including to return control of their
body to the Survivor F that evidence of
a sexual assault inside or outside New
Hampshire can be collected in New
Hampshire which is really important it
impacted my situation and G that while
evidence can be collected days after
sexual assault the sooner it is
collected the better um and once again I
appreciate the work that representative
Lon has done to take out the most
essential elements of uh that 124 pages
I do think we should include those I
understand that it's adding a lot of
language from AG's guidance and
codifying it but I I think it would be
good to include those and I still think
that all of that plus what we have in
Statue already still fits on a one
Weber and have I correctly
understood
that where is it um that e means
that the patient gets to
say yes I want this done or no I don't
want this done and if they say no I
don't want this
done um providing that they're over 18
that that controls I I assume if we're
under 18 we're we're looking at abuse
Mand mandated reporting in any
case um okay thank you yes that's yes
that is correct and that's that's within
the guidance I know we were told about
all the work that went into this and I
think that this process Honors that
I if I may just add I mean it it sounds
to me that um what is being done here is
following the lines of what's currently
done rather than creating a new scheme
so I am I am much relieved over when I
looked at it initially and thought Oh
God this is this is a whole new thing
it's it's taking bits and pieces of what
already exist and making them clearer so
very I would actually clarify that a
little bit it's what should be done but
unfortunately it's not always done so
all laws are what should be done but
yeah and I apologize for scaring anyone
with my initial bill because it always
was meant to codify what already should
be happening but very very frequently is
not and it's not just in my situation
but from the AG victim advocate own um
wording representative Palmer yeah and
my point was pretty much that what some
of the objection I heard initially was
that it was going to just create this
huge extra amount of work instead of it
just being a relatively seamless thing
that is now just not what we ought to do
but what we are required to do but it's
now as I said it would work sort of the
same way as I said as once you've once
you've heard from the patient you you
have to get this thing going but it's
going to be the same process that we
used before pretty much for any medical
facility that's doing the correct thing
according to the AG's guidelines already
yes completely no change for any medical
facility provider that is not following
AG's guidance then they're going to have
to start doing that and may I one more
followup would this is a really
practical question um the private
location within the hospital I mean I I
work I've worked both times in very
small little hospitals you're talking
about it could be just a a single room
in the ER just as long as it's not in a
room where there are three people in
beds lying next to each other I'm
assuming that's from the AG's guidance
and I'm sure representative Leon can
speak to it but I think it was always
meant to be as private as as pract
practicable yeah um the only one that
requires going into a truly private room
is if the victim wants to speak with the
advocate um separately because that is
entirely confidential and not subject to
the recordkeeping requirements of HIPPA
um as it should be as they're refed to
the rights I mean it probably could be a
closet if necessary because if you need
privacy you don't necessarily need a
patient treatment area for that
discussion so that would be the same
kind of thing as anybody who's being is
being counseled
or that where it's not just medical
treatment it's it's you know
their yeah the consultation area yeah um
and there's one area in E that that may
as you read through it again later may
feel that it may be some flowery
superflous language to the end talking
about the survivors consent is required
for each portion of the exam including
to return control of the body to the
Survivor uh the reason why I added that
language is because that's within the
guidelines you have the right to refuse
somebody has just been victimized and
the fact that they've refused a certain
part of the test doesn't mean that there
wasn't actually evidence and by spelling
that out hopefully that will prevent
overly aggressive defense attorney
saying that no the victim didn't want
that because she knew that this hadn't
happened um we don't want to impune the
person simply because she did not want
to have a swab of one of her areas where
it was not involved it's not required um
and as a lawyer I'd love your input on
that representative
Weber anybody who knew me as a lawyer
knew the criminal procedure was
absolutely out of my bailey Wick but it
did bring me another question which is
um I I understand e up to the point of
the comma require is required for each
portion of the exam but I don't think I
understand the plain English meaning of
including to return control of their
body to the Survivor because I don't
understand the meaning
of when control of their I mean I
understand lack of control issues that
go along with both sexual assault and
medical
treatment but I guess I'm not
understanding what those mean words are
intended to do um thank you actually my
intention is so that it's clear that
somebody has that right to do that
they're there specifically because
control of their body was removed
through this assault or attempted
assault and the informed consent of each
part has more than just our individual
choices but also the fact that you're
trying to reclaim some autonomy after an
attack it's not worded well um and I
would appreciate some language I I it
was too late put a period after exam
because the the point is that the
survivor's consent is required for each
portion so if the Survivor says I want
samples T these samples taken but I
don't want these samples
taken that should be their decision and
and that is in fact returning control of
their body to them because they are
being treated in ways they say they want
to be treated as opposed to how they're
told they're going to be treated um but
I I think and I will speak as a lawyer
um although I'm not a lawyer and I
cannot practice in this state because
I'm retired um I think I think that that
last Lang language while it does Express
the intent of this whole thing which is
to return control to somebody who has
been subjected to external controls I I
think it doesn't help in terms of saying
what we're going to do so I would just
line that part out if if that was
acceptable to other people and and put a
period after exam and that is the
operative phase that allows the patient
to
determine what they desire to have
happen um I I do think that there are
some of the legal issues around it as
well that probably will need to be come
come back next year um in the AG's
guidance it does say there was some of
the concern and push back was that by
informing people of the ability to take
the drug or urine test there may be some
people that because of either
prescriptions that they're on or their
own choices whether for legal drugs like
alcohol or the recreational choices
because they decided to do cocaine that
day that that is not an excuse or a
reason for them to be sexually assaulted
and that's within the prosecution
guidelines that nobody is to be charged
if they are positive for recreational
drugs or drug misuse um I I think that
it actually would be important for us to
come back probably to clarify that
denial of some of these tests is not
grounds for saying that somebody is is
trying to lie to the one but that's not
something to handle here that's a bill
that we probably hopefully we can all
commit to working on assuming we're all
here again next session to bring that to
criminal justice to help close that Loop
but I think that this bill with even
without that line that I couldn't word
quite well I think moves us quite
forward um I guess at this point I'm
curious if anybody has any more input
any concerns um representative McDonald
we haven't heard from you yet well in in
a room full of doctors and lawyers
former lawyers and and medical
professionals uh it wasn't a lot for me
to add I do have a question and it's
been um it's been touched on the initial
uh hearing on the bill uh the New
Hampshire Association against domestic
sexual violence testified against this
bill do we any does anyone have any
insight as to why that was the case um I
I actually went and I looked through
their website to see what information
they provided I was quite concerned when
they testified um when they said that
somebody who hadn't been penit ated did
not need to have a rape kit so I looked
at their guidance and what they said in
in an response to that question was
inconsistent with the guidance from the
Coalition um so if you look at their
actual guidance and what they provide to
patients it says that penetration does
not need to occur for a sexual assault
so unfortunately we got incorrect
information in that hearing about the
policies and the use the person may have
misspoken or misunderstood the bill per
yes it may have been related to the them
thinking that because the attempted
assault did not say attempted sexual
assault that may have been what the
issue was because they may have thought
that this was hitting somebody over the
head and and they were equating it there
representative Palmer and to to what you
were just saying um some of that may
have been that they were worried that it
would be and when we started this we
were talking about the wording here that
may have been misleading and I I think
some of the testimony might have
been going for that where it's just like
somebody might walk in they were at a
bar and they got a drink and they felt
funny afterwards but there was no
question of assault but they just want
to go to the ER and get tested to see if
they got drugged and they were worried
that that would tie up a whole ER room
and lead to a whole lot of um problem so
if this if the first that first line is
corrected that takes away that problem
um because it's just pertaining to
drugged
for sexual assault yes if you look at
the the language given to us um that
representative Reed and I worked on we
also changed the title of the bill uh
because that title um reflected the
previous one reflected the wrong
information this would change it to an
act expanding the information provided
to survivors of sexual assault regarding
their existing rights and just as a note
um I came into that initial Hearing in
the spring with an amendment changing
that initial title because the title was
always incorrect it always the title
implied that the doctor would be storing
the evidence and that never happens it's
the police so it was just an incorrectly
worded title from the get-go but yes it
the what the bill has always been
intended to do and what it does now uh
with this language is simply expand the
information that is provided to
survivors about their existing rights
representative
Weber and I'm just looking at a
communication from the Coalition that
that again speaks to the bill is not
consistent with current practices and
protocols and it sounds to me not
knowing precisely what those are that
the bill is now far better and far more
clearly aligned with current protocols
and has a better descriptive title as
well so um I'm
I'm in unless I
hear otherwise from somebody who isn't
here or isn't available um and I don't I
don't know the person who came in so I
don't know if they have
any comments or whether you as chair or
we as a committee want to hear them but
I'm seeing a head shaking no um I I I am
much more comfortable with this
formulation
so um my thought with us is especially
because we don't have any of the other
stakeholders here perhaps we should see
if anybody wants to send us information
to the subcommittee through this next
Friday we can notice a subcommittee
meeting even U with only 24 hours notice
and there is past history of
subcommittees meeting 15 minutes after
the conclusion of a house session which
we do have scheduled next Thursday um my
thought would be that we see if this is
actually consistent because I believe we
were following the requests of those
stakeholders who Express concerns get
their feedback um assuming that that
there's agreement on this we I will get
this language drafted up into an
amendment that we can circulate and then
we can notice to come back and discuss
that um I can notice things separately
if we end up having a much bigger issue
because I would rather us deal with this
I I I think that we've actually reached
a fantastic fantastic point on this bill
and we're honoring the actual intent um
as opposed to the way it was just tucked
in with an extra extra addition in the
statutes so I think in terms of
procedure uh the next important thing is
to get this drafted
and
um my concern is I don't know when it
gets widely available up on a website
it's usually not up on the website until
somebody's offered it correct
so my concern is how do we make sure I
mean in terms of notice anybody who
wanted to comment or know what was going
on with this should be here and maybe
they're watching at home and that's
that's fine and that's their right I
just want to be sure that we can make
the language available so and and I
presumably anybody who's watching
anybody who's watching uh could contact
you and have the language provided to
them which I will have which is the
important thing I will have this drafted
and then anybody who's watching at home
or watching later contact me I will send
you the language um and then we would
like to have this information uh I guess
no later than Monday that gives people
to look at it over the weekend the end
of Monday so we can make sure that we're
moving forward the correct way um and I
think
that and I need to know specifically
where this deviates from the guidelines
because all of this language is coming
directly from the statutes and from the
guidelines which govern this so um I I
would need to have any objections be
quite specific to see if there's any
issues I think that would be very
helpful because it also helps with
drafting if if something is yes I I will
put together um our Proto drafting if we
weren't in the middle of of Bill
drafting season where everybody is still
trying to get their language back on
their lsrs it would be a lot easier to
keep popping these different ones
through o OS but I want to make sure
that um we have this information we make
it available to people but also we're
not over taxing OS because I I think
that I think that if they had had a
little bit more time to work on this
bill in the first place we would have
dealt with this and passed this bill
last fall quite honestly if we had
gotten to this information at that point
that might be presumptive that's not
their job no it's not but when you send
the request it's a matter of do you
stick it in at the end sure or are you
responding very quickly and we're all
working through the quick process
because I remember last year there were
some bills we had to sign off on before
we even had the final text because we
were dealing with people who were with
Co out with maternity leaves and dealing
with the fact that we're the largest
we're the third largest English speaking
language legislature with the smallest
OS so I'm glad we are all able to work
together as a team um the legislature OS
and everybody else as well so um does
anybody else have any um any
forward a question this is a question so
um as representative Weber said I'm way
more comfortable because it's I my main
concern was not was was having something
that was just too cumbersome to work
well and as long as we can make
something works that works well that'll
be great um because I think the intent I
I you know don't disagree with the
intent at all it was just how to make it
work so that it works properly and
smoothly for everybody um so my question
is we passed the bill and so somebody
now has to sort of make the rules
and I'm a little vague on how that
happens um thank you I am you're G to be
yes so one of the challenges and one of
the reasons why it's perhaps better we
don't have a form is that form would
have to go through jel car The Joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules um I have the honor of reading
through 300 pages of rules every month
um to vote on so that will go through
the process it'll provide the
information that is available um this it
I I'm not sure that this actually falls
under rulemaking you simply you simply
would need to there's the information
where it directs the AG to give the
information to um everybody who's one of
the providers so because this was the
the 124 page guidance and the other um
complimentary Guidance with the action
steps wasn't through Ru making they can
take this information and have it in a
form that hopefully is available far
more prominently on the Attorney
General's website for child crimes and
for other crimes they're very close to
the top of what's available on the
Attorney General's website and I would
encourage them that assuming that we do
pass this and we move forward that this
information about the sexual assault
survivors rights is prominent because
sexual assaults an epidemic the other
thing is that if we don't have to go
through the rule making
process the information will be
available to patients months and months
earlier and I think that all of us would
be more comfortable with that I oh I'm
sorry representative kushman sure I just
want to speak to how I Envision it to
happen and say in Ed um you know you
just once it
passes they literally print out 18 and
19 and staple it together or have it
front and back and it goes in a filing
cabinet and then a patient comes in who
says I've been sexually assaulted or um
I think it was drugged someone was
trying to to harm me
sexually and they say oh and they tell
the nurse please get her the you know
the patient rights and delegation is
included under this you know what I mean
anything that you can delegate doesn't
need to be stated um explicitly so um so
they just say make sure you get that
patient you know that form or the that
statute
that paper that's in the file and then
they give it and then they go from
there if I can that's precisely what I
was imagining as well it's um the parts
that had had to be dealt with
administratively have already been dealt
with administratively that's why we have
124 Pages um but literally just as far
as you know how it's actually enacted
every individual hospital or provider
would just have whatever their print off
is they could format it however they
like and just pass it out when someone
says they're they were
assaulted thank you uh so I so as we
look through all of this the
subcommittee doesn't need to take actual
action on our Amendment so we'll solicit
information from other stakeholders
through the end of the day next Monday
um the 23rd um and we'll see depending
on that on that input that we get um I
assume that I'm not not expecting much
push back um if that's the case then we
probably are able to move forward to
this bring it to Executive session if we
have need for another work session I'll
contact all of you and we'll figure out
whether it's a short one um immediately
following session or if we have one that
we schedule separately fa that process
work for everybody y fantastic and with
that I thank you all and I call this
you